[Music]
Dessie we're here at beautycon at 2018
what has the fan reaction been for you
everybody here is so amazing and I'm
just so in awe of everyone's makeup here
it's like the one place you go to when
everybody looks perfection like I've
never seen so many cut creases in my
life so what did you bring with you
today like in your bag to keep you fresh
all day okay my number one thing that I
always touch up with is the Charlotte
Tilbury airbrush finished powder because
it is the best and it's just like if you
get a little oily boom boom boom and it
doesn't take up which is important yeah
so what is the strangest thing we would
find in your beauty bag um probably I
don't know strange but I have like a
foldable straw it's like so I don't have
to use plastic straw so I like whip it
out like a it's like a sword boom you
don't mess up that lip gloss you can't
mess up the lip gloss okay you can't you
have to have one which what's your first
memory of makeup I'll never forget I saw
my mom doing her winged eyeliner in the
car and she did it so perfect in two
seconds and I was just like I said how
did you how do you do that and she said
don't worry honey one day you'll be able
to do it too and then I said yeah right
and here you are and Here I am at
beautycon 2018 and you've had your own
beauty line with dose of colors you had
your glam will we get a Katy desi club
again I mean anything is possible you
guys anything is possible in the works
anything is possible
I don't know I don't know
and key Australia you just celebrated
your two-year anniversary and stayin
busy
you have surpassed all a listers that
have done collabs with this branch it
has been a dream I've always wanted to
be a designer and do fashion things and
so this opportunity turned into
something that I had no idea would be
and now it's just I love it so much I
love it
nothing is better than seeing people
wearing my sunglasses and JLo where's
your line I die I'm maluma I die
[Music]
Demi Lovato Becky jeez I I just died
every time I'm in I'm still in shock